russia slowed down twitter speed
and threatened a total block after the
site allegedly
failed to delete banned content if
twitter
continues to ignore the requirements of
the law the enforcement
measured will be continued the state
communication regulator said think about
that
the move which escalates a grown
standoff between moscow and u.s social
media comes weeks after russian
authorities accuse twitter
and others are failing to delete posts
it said
illegally urge children to take part in
the anti-kremlin protest
the regulators claims that the vast
majority of the post twitter allegedly
refused to delete contained content
encouraging miners to take their own
lives other police including
in the indecent images of children and
information about drug abuse moscow has
gradually introduced tougher internet
laws in recent years requiring secret
search engines to delete some search
results
messaging services to share encryption
keys etc etc etc tom
what do you by the way russia tried to
ban telegram messenger since 2018 for
example but proved technically unable to
block the app
and last year he publicly lifted the ban
what do you think russia is doing here
going after twitter
um i think there's a there is a not so
humorous
truth that's in the middle of that and
that is you are encouraging children to
take their own lives
what are you talking about you're
encouraging them to speak against the
government oh i see so
you're that's how you take your own life
you speak against the government yeah
and you get disappeared
right um look russia hey
russia really hasn't changed that much i
mean since the soviet union broke
you know they've been trying to put it
back together and the biggest thing
you're trying to put back together is
your control systems
and information you know and
human yearning for freedom are
things that are catalysts for massive
change and the government doesn't want
change i think it's as simple as that
and this window to the world they don't
want it this soapbox to speak
um they don't want it ronald reagan told
a great joke
and he said um he was talking to a
russian friend
and he says i think the united states
great for the freedom they said why do
you say that
and ronald reagan said because any
citizen in america
can walk in to the president's office
and pound his fist on the table and say
mr reagan i don't like how you're
running your country
and the russian guy says i can do that
too so what do you mean i can walk into
gorbachev's office i can pound my fist
on the table and i said i don't like how
mr reagan's running his country
and i don't think anything's changed
it's just these digital russia still
russia russia
russia how much of this liability is on
twitter how much of this is backfiring
on twitter based on how they mishandled
prior incidents uh i think they need to
be careful that
arrogance against american controls
doesn't play well
other places like china and russia how
how ugly could this get i mean what can
russia really do to twitter let's face
it what can
what do you do you can't you can't bomb
a social media platform and say i'm
going to blow you up twitter
well what do you do i think it's great
hackers i mean we all know russia's got
great hackers we're going to talk about
it a little later but microsoft right
now is under a state-sponsored attack
from china yep
so i i you've got some smart people over
there and i think you know
digital attacks digital warfare
i i think that's exactly where they go
with this
okay well i mean back to your initial
thought uh you know of complaining
against the the government of uh
of russia obviously putin's in charge
there what's the name of the gentleman
who's been
the biggest dissident and uh detractor
of uh
putin and nexi alexei navalny right
we've heard
we've seen this guy's story over the
germans took three months in hospitals
okay so he was poisoned on a plane we
saw we we played that that video
sort of in one in the initial podcast
yep he's back to the plane oh my god
they take him off the plane it turns out
he was poisoned and
clearly this was a germany savings in
life germany saves his life shout out to
your people
and uh i'm canadian by the way okay i
didn't you know just
go along with it baby um
the um what does this guy do he
you know recovers and what does he do he
goes back to russia
and essentially dares putin to kill him
again he gets arrested where's it
what's the status of him now he puts him
on trial and puts him in a tough prison
that's where he's there right now is he
not
i don't know that's my point is that you
speak out about against the government
uh poisoned you know imprisoned
good luck out there i mean back to your
point about the the russian joke
back to your point with twitter how do
you fight a social media company if
you're a
strong man like putin it's just hacking
digital warfare is that the only
um outlet you have to doing something
like this
kai what can they really do to twitter
can they do anything to twitter outside
of
you can't poison twitter or can you tom
can they do anything to twitter you
don't have an answer for that i think
they
they just shut it off right because
russia controls internet over there
yeah they'll shut up they limit they
limit access so nobody into
in russia yeah can they do anything to
the actual network
i think just uh tweeting or uh hacking
bots
kind of that stuff they can do some
stuff which obviously can do damage
because remember the bitcoin scam that
happened with twitter
on the users and stuff like that well
according to cnn they can steal
elections
it's uh it's it's proven by cnn folks
and i've seen
cnn say you know of course clearly
that's your community so if you enjoyed
this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye